i never forget a face i know you don't
and in years to come you might find
yourself
revisiting a few but just
the old favorites
what
[Music]
[Music]
you know i swear the bbc times these
kinds of announcements just uh
mess with my entire day
so uh i know lots of people got their
hot takes and responses out yesterday
when the news was announced but you know
i'm busy and i got crap that i'm trying
to do like
trying to get my new computer sorted
it's here it's set up but you know i had
to get all the software updated on and
make sure it had all the things i needed
on it some of the software for my laptop
wasn't
working well so i had to update stuff
and like
it's been a thing
anyways
we need to talk about
doctor who
and the new
old
showrunner
now in charge because bbc officially
announced
yesterday
that russell t
davis
the man
who brought back
doctor who
in the modern era way back in 2005
is coming back
to show run
obviously this is
kind of huge and not something that i
i at least saw anybody
even clocking as a vague possibility i
mean you know i had my own um video that
i did which because i had gotten
information that indicated they were
looking at sally wainwright i know a lot
of people were really in favor of j
michael straczynski taking over he was
kind of lobbying for the job and there
was were that the bbc actually met with
him and i'm not gonna say i never heard
anybody say oh it should be davies but
that was almost always like this weird
nostalgic oh wouldn't it be nice if he
came back i never heard anybody say it
as if they actually thought it was a
possibility it would happen and so
it's now happened and it's kind of
blindsided everybody
my own thoughts on this
are
kind of mixed
so first of all i'll reiterate the fact
that i'm not really sad that chibnall's
leaving while i have not been completely
absent of things to like during his era
his overall approach hasn't really
panned out particularly well for me and
most of the episodes that i
don't like
are actually written by him
so
my thoughts on chipnold going out you
know i i'm not as spiteful or as
celebratory at
the idea of him leaving as some people
are but i certainly wasn't bemoaning it
but now the idea of bringing back
someone who ran the show previously
is
on the one hand
exciting because of the specifics of who
we're talking about but on the other
hand
and the broad strokes in the general
idea has me very concerned
so
why don't i start
with why it's kind of exciting
because davey's it's not like he's been
sitting around doing nothing
like just to make a comparison because
there's no one else for me to compare it
to if they were to say try and bring
back moffat
first of all i'm not sure moffat's been
gone long enough for people to miss him
specifically even people who didn't like
chimpanel i don't think too many of them
were calling for the return of moffat
and more to the point
while i'm not going to say he hasn't
been doing anything since he left doctor
who his output has been very much in
keeping kind of what's standard for him
and he hasn't done all that much of
note at least
i kind of don't think so
whereas davies has been very busy he has
been doing all sorts of things and
most importantly i think
really feels like he's grown and changed
as an artist
since he was the showrunner for doctor
who he's done things like years and
years and it's a sin he's really kind of
dug deep into some real
heartbreaking and
dark places not that i necessarily want
him to bring that kind of darkness to
doctor who but i'm saying that he hasn't
been staying put he hasn't been treading
water as an artist
so with him specifically i actually get
a little bit more excited
because it's him more so than i would in
terms of the general premise i'll talk
about my issues with the general idea of
an ultra runner coming back in a little
bit
so what's exciting with him specifically
is
i don't have as much of a fear that he's
just gonna try and recapture what he did
before i don't think he would have come
back if all he felt that he was either
capable of doing or that the bbc would
allow him to do would be to just
give us more of the exact kind of thing
he was doing previously i don't i think
he's got
too much clout and too much artistic
ambition to come back if that was the
case if he either thought he had nothing
to add or if he thought the bbc was
gonna restrain him and basically say
look don't do new stuff do the old stuff
that people already like
now granted that's supposition on my
part it is distinctly possible
especially given the fact that he's
bringing back his old producing partners
that maybe once he's back with that
creative team on this kind of property
again it will bring back the kind of
artistic instincts that he
may have otherwise moved on from that's
possible
i
have as i said a little bit more
confidence that i might otherwise that i
don't think that's gonna happen
however
i do have my broad concerns about the
fact that it's happening at all
because the idea of bringing back an old
showrunner
okay so
there are basically two perspectives
that i'm going to address in this part
looking at where it makes 100 total
perfect sense
but why it makes me concerned anyways
so from a strictly business i p
management sense in terms of what is the
best thing for this intellectual
property as far as the business end of
things this
is basically perfect this is the bbc's
ideal solution on a silver platter
because
you know regardless of what anyone
thinks specifically about the chibnall
arrow whether they liked it whether they
loathed it you cannot ignore the fact
that it sure as heck was divisive now
i'm always one to point out that the
doctor who fandom has always had
disagreements amongst itself from well
before i've been here and well before
chibnall came along but those things
have gotten harsher now i'm not
necessarily going to say that's
chibnall's fault but business management
side is going to look at that and go
okay
how do we come back from this very
divided time and again from a business
perspective the best thing to do is to
bring back someone who made it exciting
and got people on board in the first
place because look it's unlikely that
anyone who stuck around through the
whitaker era or who jumped on board
during it and liked it is going to
suddenly bail because of davey showing
up
and he's probably about the only person
they could put in who would bring in the
most people who bounced off the show
during chibnall's era now that's not to
say that they wouldn't have come back if
it was say j michael strzinski or sally
wayne wright or any number of another
people toby woodhouse who the heck knows
but
it i think there would have been a
little bit more hesitancy there there
would have been a little bit more okay
but i'm not sure what they're gonna do
and maybe it won't be any better whereas
davies has a body of work specific to
doctor who and it's the kind of
excitement that honestly people had
about moffat when he was first announced
because his existing body of work and
doctor who was extremely beloved at the
time he took the show over
and so this is kind of getting that same
pop and i don't think any other name
creative name would give the bbc and the
show the same pop from the fans as
bringing back davies and so from a
business perspective this has the
possibility of
calming the fans down and getting
everybody back on board or at the very
least getting way more people that might
have otherwise done so
the
incentive to come in and give series 14
or whatever they end up calling it a
chance under davies
now
as i said it makes total sense from a
business perspective of ip management
from a creative perspective of iep
management this is why
i am a little bit nervous and a little
bit antsy again not about davis
specifically i think i'm fairly
confident that he's going to do
something interesting and i don't think
he's going to fall back on just
regurgitating what he did before
but
i the very mentality
at the bbc at the people making the
hiring decisions that would lead to the
decision to bring back an old showrunner
at all
that mentality
makes me nervous
i think that one of the most frustrating
ways for a
piece of entertainment a long-running
narrative a well-established
long-running narrative piece of
entertainment is to just start
looking back
and to spend endless amounts of time
trying to recapture its old glory
and again from a business perspective
trying to recapture the old glory it's a
really good thing but from a creative
perspective and for the sake of not
having the thing stagnate creatively
that makes me nervous
again not because i think davis himself
will do that but because if that's the
mentality of the people making the
hiring decisions right now on the crea
uh you know of who is going to get to
run the show
what else might they do or what else
might they encourage
it's the kind of thing that
honestly
frustrated the heck out of me with the
star trek franchise for a long long time
and honestly these days i see way more
enthusiasm for star trek than i have in
ages and it's partly because that these
days they're actually doing
new stuff like properly new stuff they
did some interesting things with
discovery picard is finally set further
in the future lower decks is a
completely different beast altogether
but still feels like star trek it is
finally moving forward instead of trying
to
look back at what it used to be and go
well how do we get that back again well
let's reboot it as movies and like oh
well that's not working and there was
there was a real sense of desperation to
star trek for a while and i don't want
that for doctor who it's also honestly
part of why i bounced off of reading
monthly comic book issues
because
ultimately no matter where things went
good or bad
almost everything would eventually get
rolled back
now granted in that case i'm kind of
talking about retcons and that's not
really what i mean but it's that same
mentality this idea of okay we've gone
in a direction but let's put it back
where it was whether you do that
literally in terms of a full status quo
and continuity reset or whether you do
it philosophically in terms of how you
approach the material that
will always make me nervous i am on
record in a video as saying that i don't
think it would be worth it to retcon the
timeless child now i'll explain why i'm
bringing this up in a second and just to
reiterate i
hate the timeless child i absolutely
hate that decision
but
i don't think that it's worth it for the
show to get so
hung up on its own past
for a future showrunner to try and wreck
on it or fix it
that's not
where the energy should go the energy
should be going towards moving forward
not looking back
now there are still things to be
benefited from the past you can look at
what did or didn't work you can look at
okay well here's a character or a story
or whatever worth revisiting that's okay
to a point but literally trying to go
back and be like okay you know we need
to make it like it was before that's an
unhealthy mentality for the lifespan and
the life blood the creative lifeblood of
any intellectual property not just
doctor who any of them and again
it's not that this specific decision
makes me think we're screwed and it's
all going to be navel gazing from here
on out
but i worry about the mentality that it
signals
of what else might happen later and i
try not to get too doom and gloom about
it but that is where my head's at right
now do i think that we're screwed no not
necessarily i mean people
change in terms of who the decision
makers are so even this mentality that
i'm talking about at the bbc
may not be that long lived if it's there
at all
but the thought's still there
in my head and i still worry
about
that
happening because doctor who and i've
said it before possibly more than any
other property has the ability to self
refresh
without having to do things like massive
retcons and rollbacks of the narrative
doctor who
more than any other show i know has the
ability to always move forward and the
idea that it would ever stop and start
looking back
instead
i just don't think would be good for it
and i think long term
uh fans wouldn't like it either
it's the kind of thing that creates an
insular
situation where only the people who
appreciate the way it used to be enjoy
it anymore
and i know there are certainly some
people out there who would like that and
don't want new fans and they want to be
strictly catered to but again that's the
kind of nonsense that bounced me off of
comic books now
i have
seen that a whole bunch of hot takes are
up i have not listened watched or read
them
because well i want to get my own
thoughts out there but also because i
kind of don't want to sink into it
i know just from titles of videos there
are
whole swaths of people out there who are
treating this like it's a victory
as if chibnall was an enemy to be
defeated and that's just a relationship
with
the creative end of a show that is so
antagonistic that i kind of want no part
of it but here's what i'll say in terms
of going forward i will be very curious
to see
what the reaction is when davies
actually starts putting out episodes
because i have a feeling
that
if he does what i expect him to do and
to do something different and not just
refresh and do what he did again that
there are going to be
certain corners of fandom decrying how
he's lost his touch and he's not as good
anymore many of whom will probably be
willfully ignorant to
how davies actually ran the show before
like the fact that it used to be
a bit campier than it got later on and
the fact that he had a lot of politics
very baked in to a lot of the stuff that
he wrote and that his work since doctor
who has only gotten more outright
political i will not be shocked
to see um
certain folks within
fan circles turn on davies when they
either
realize properly for the first time or
remember
just how political this guy is
and can be and has been
and should be
he's good at it
because gymnal wasn't great
on that stuff so again davey's back
because it's him and
again not because i think he's the
greatest thing ever there were issues
with his era i would be happy to go over
them if you want me to but i'm trying to
be as positive as i can right now even
with my concerns but he's back and i am
kind of excited because of who he's
become as an artist as opposed to
thinking oh he will bring back what it
was before i don't think he will or at
least i hope he won't because i want him
to do something new because that's what
i always want doctor who to do in some
way
is to move forward and do something new
i really
really
don't
want to see
people start speculating or saying that
they should bring back an older actor to
play the doctor again
and yes i know dave the doctor kind of
very strongly hinted that that was a
possibility that he could take on a face
that he had before i i don't care this
is not about the continuity or whether
or not it fits it's about that
stagnation that i talked about before
and about that that wouldn't even be
looking backward that'd be staring up
its own butthole if the show did that
so
i swear i just just i just saw glimpses
of headlines of of speculation of either
tenant or smith coming back no
no
i want to see what davies will do
but the reason is is because i trust him
to do something new
don't turn this into
let's
make it what it used to be
those are my thoughts
on russell t davies coming back to show
run doctor who
what are your thoughts
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it be
polite
to me
to davies and to jib no i'm really sick
of having to scrub comments that are
absolute vitriol about a guy that the
video i'm making isn't even about
really sick of it
you can tell that that's kind of become
a button for me
but as long as you don't do that
i'd love to hear your thoughts on this i
have a patreon and that is how i pay my
bills keep this whole operation up and
running and was able to afford that new
computer i've spent the last couple days
trying to get fully set up and
everything
uh the way i want it
but any amount you're able to assist is
greatly appreciated if you can't or
don't want to use that there's youtube
memberships if you don't want to do that
like share subscribe it'll help me out
you know what hit the bell i never tell
people to do that go ahead hit the bell
but don't worry about that either
because at the end of the day
you are the council i'm only running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
this video wouldn't have been possible
without the support of my patrons and i
want to give special thanks to jared
boyce
mj the doctor tracy scrabbit vincent
paul bartolucci hayley schwartz
edelman
robin moore ross schultz and shayla
gordon
thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]